couldn't miss the opportunity to put two
great environmental minds head to head
in an
earth day trivia showdown
here's how it works we'll play these
three rounds based on the three
r's of earth day reduce recycle and
reuse
now each correct answer is worth one
point i'm excited to introduce
our next evolution of trophies it's the
earth day trophy
and if neil degrasse tyson thinks it's
beautiful
it's already engraved with his name
okay to raise the stakes danny has
brought some special gifts for our vffs
danny if you will
if i win you're all gonna get this
beautiful olivia burton watch we love
olivia burton it's a british brand that
really took off in england it's now over
here
it's all inspired by nature and the
stars and
that's astronomy it has a vegan straps a
really beautiful 145
i believe for the watch but here's what
you're really getting because when neil
wins
[Laughter]
you're going to get a prize from my
favorite website to shop at it's olive
and cocoa and olive and cocoa they use
these beautiful
wood crates that are reusable full of
healthy earth-friendly
fun edible gifts succulents there's so
many things when you can't find the
perfect gift go to olive and coco and
they would all you'll all get a hundred
i'm so nervous i'm just gonna they're
all gonna get a hundred dollar gift card
to olive and coco
okay here we go round one
[Music]
question 200 million pounds of this is
thrown away every year and it doesn't
break down naturally very easily
it is do you want to try uh chewing gum
it's it's okay danny
now get nervous all right here we go
oh sorry what and okay here's the
solution to reduce the amount of chewing
gum that you chew try chewing on organic
mints
or a sprig of parsley okay question is
it vital that we reduce
the amount of plastic going into our
oceans which ocean has the largest
accumulation of plastic
was that that was a charity weight i'm
gonna say
i'm gonna say pacific this
is known as the area of the great
pacific
garbage patch and if you want to see on
our globe this is literally where it
is and one thing that we can all do to
reduce ocean plastic is to participate
in beach cleanups or simply pick up
trash on the ground
when we see it by the way the pacific
ocean because it's so large that's where
we drop
satellites that we don't use anymore
really they fall out of space and they
go
so sky lab is in the pacific ocean yeah
that's the big toilet bowl for space
debris oh i hate that the ocean is a
toilet bowl
okay next round reuse
[Applause]
a great way to reuse food is to compost
but which of the following is
not recommended for composting dryer
lint
hair and fur or fish bones
danny seemed to get get that buzzer
there are loopholes i'm gonna go with
dryer lint because it depends on the
type of detergent you use
and no and
if you dried synthetic fibers that are
in the lint so they're not
technically compostable go to twitter
okay
neil your turn uh
i was gonna say dryer lint too okay you
guys
guess what it is none of that it is fish
bones
fish bones and other animal bones take
long
very long time to break down dryer lint
is carbon rich and will decompose
easily and surprisingly hair and fur
contains tons of nitrogen
perfect for the healthy compost pile
okay go to the bonus sex on the city
question
okay meanwhile
on planet earth i had to wonder
okay reuse which of these plastic
containers should
not be reused this salad container
this soup container or this pad thai
container
none of them should be reused nail
i would say the pad thai container
neither of you
are correct and i don't mean that
belittlingly or patronized
it's this salad container it's not
reusable
it's made of plastic one which is safe
for
single use but it is not a good idea to
reuse
because it has that porous surface that
traps bacteria
all right final round recycle
which one of these items is not
recyclable
the wet cereal box magazines
magazines danny
a wet cereal box magazines a used pizza
box
pizza box it is pizza box
pizza box yes so how come i can recycle
other sort of corrugated boxes and not a
pizza box that's a good question well
neil
astrophysicist from danny ceo lifestyle
expert i will tell you
that because of the grease and cheese
that's absorbed by cardboard pizza box
that makes it non-recyclable not only
shouldn't you recycle it but it can
contaminate an entire
load of recyclables by trying to do it
but if it didn't have the grease and
cheese in it you can i have to say
that my body responds like a recycling
bin it does not recycle pizza
okay which of these holiday items is
recyclable plastic easter grass
christmas lights holiday lights you are
correct
um congratulations to our earth day
trivia champion showdown it is danny
this is the best broccoli gift ever
and uh vff's not only did danny win
but you guys are the biggest winners of
them all because you get
both gifts
now i want to be a vif so i can get i
know by the way i feel the same way i'm
totally greedy right now i'm like i want
everything too
it's been such an honor to do this with
you today
and cosmic queries is available now in
bookstores it includes
literature writing tweets it really
breaks it down in a way that i think
every generation can truly respond to
thank you
so much congrats danny
[Music]